[Music]
in destroy the enemy news submitted by
Jojo Nomo Oh a seven year old woman went
through two rounds of hitmen to get
revenge holy Sh I don't know why I
pictured an old lady that was weird but
seventy year old oh that's literally
what she said either holy [ __ ] man why
it's like two two times though I picture
two senior hitman two homies they're
like old mob guys the other schema stuff
I did but then just like the oxygen tank
is like name is Linda Linda from Salt
Lake City Utah she looks like oh you
like sweet she looks like a [ __ ] to me
she looks like that lady that [ __ ]
know she'd like be measuring like if
your lemon tree is growing over her
third grade teacher that kicked me out
of school her haircut is not very
friendly she better have the curls
no she doesn't look 70 she's she looks
like maybe in her 50s no 17 mom's age
right now got 70 my mom is 60 when you
get the labia neck you're like 70
because when I picture 70s I picture
down here like a bulldog for 70 I think
you're thinking like 80 or not you think
80 so she was found guilty of conspiring
to have her ex-husband killed damn and a
divorce ready let me tell you this [ __ ]
is kind of funny in my opinion to
contact her to this one guy right - fine
like this guy was supposed to find
someone to kill her ex-husband and she
even said like you know what if he kills
the new wife - then I wouldn't care
either [ __ ] it two people killed and she
promised the sum of $25,000 total that's
not a lot of money so it would be five
thousand down payment
seven thousand
diamond ring and 18,000 from the
victim's life insurance policies Wow
which she would collect after his death
and so but then that do that that she
approached he you just felt so guilty
that he approached the police instead
what kind of hitman is this maybe he
just started yeah this is first job he
was supposed to be finding the hitman oh
he's a hitman agent yeah headhunter for
a hitman yeah so the name is Christian
and so Christian your name yeah yeah so
she was trying to get someone alright he
wasn't a professional this this sounds
like a comedy movie though yeah I know
this is the Coen Brothers film it's
Fargo yeah anyway so she was trying to
get Christian to make it look like an
accident or a break and gone wrong
anyway Christian went to the police and
he also went to the ex-husband to let
him know about everything else oh my god
Christian he wore a wire and then got
evidence that she wanted him dead so she
goes to jail then when she's in jail she
meets this inmate and she tells us
inmate like alright I'm gonna pay for
your bail you gotta find me someone to
kill Christian because he was supposed
to kill my ex-husband two people
oh she ends up paying for the bail and
and then she gives her lawyer a letter
pretty much i constructing how like she
wants Christian to be killed but then
the lawyer well the lawyer was supposed
to hand off the letter but I don't know
if the lawyer knew who's this [ __ ]
Saul Goodman or whatever his name is
legal lawyer she handed her lawyer a
check for a hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars issued to oh [ __ ]
inmate that she bailed out yeah I'm
spending so much money for things so
angry that's a lot of when you hate
someone you gotta get rid of him i
misstated what the letter was it was a
confessed letter that she wanted to have
Christian sign so then it would just
absolve everything like pretty much him
saying that he made everything yeah
that was what the letter was so he has
to admit to that and he's gonna get
murdered what a [ __ ]
she just does not let go oh it isn't
good plants either at all
she was asking the former inmate to make
sure that the Hitman was willing to kill
Christian and like the ex-husband but
yeah so the police in the jail they
confiscated the letter from the lawyer
and so they never got to the former
inmate but she got cut trying to get to
hitman feel like she like lives in her
own her own world or her own movie like
in her mind if she's like I want you to
kill my husband then I want you to kill
the ex the other hit then and everyone
else in that world is like lady I don't
know I please they're not even criminal
yeah you look like a kind of guy that
likes hitmen she's like you know an
action star in her own movie why are you
talking to me with the back face yeah
with you [ __ ] she was trying to get
that the second event to also kill this
other lawyer that was doing her she's
probably doing her so she was trying to
kill the lawyer that was suing her but
hitman that was the first hitman and
then her ex-husband and ex-husbands new
wife
and what does she have all this money
yeah she's like a bad guy in a layer
like you'll see you'll all be dead yo be
dead i won she does look like a villain
dos polical villain right I wonder how
many years
she's got away with doing that like how
many people has she paid off like she's
just writing checks left to right you
[ __ ] me you [ __ ] me and you [ __ ] I want
to look at her venmo transaction
ladies trying to kill anyone that causes
her Bob yeah you think she's been saving
up like this is her retirement fund like
she's been like waiting yeah yeah 30
he's like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna
give to you it keeps a list like a
grocer in a store that gave her the
wrong change finally for her retirement
instead of going to vacation and going
on a cruise like most old people she's
gonna start her dreams her best life
dude her behaviors like like a [ __ ]
hot girl that like just realize that
she's no longer hot so she's like [ __ ]
what else do I use now I'm gonna just
kill people oh no [ __ ] a grudge hold
nas [ __ ] you know and it's funny
because in this article they were like
well her sentencing has been scheduled
for April 23rd she faces life in prison
but you know there's still time to kill
everyone else and then she could get all
free that's funny
I'm outta 23rd well she's only in prison
for that long no that's when her
sentencing is gonna I was like that's
only a month so she has a month to kill
everyone she's out right now she's free
no she's in jail it's a joke gosh I yeah
a joke like you know she has a month
gotcha okay it's not funny it was funny
when I read it in the article anyway
it's funny what kind of a [ __ ] do you
have to be to hold a grudge that hard
and that long and like for that many
people it's like a gambling addict like
she didn't win the first time she's like
I can win the second one and then she
keeps losing and losing she's like I
look kill more people you know and like
one of these is gonna hit ya so she she
wants to kill her husband and then the
guy that hired she hires to kill her
husband fail so she wants to kill that
guy yeah
and either one in the look-around
employer like it's like she has to make
up for all the losses so she's like I'm
just gonna add more to the list that's a
lot of money that's like a total of like
200 grand that she promised already
I mean at that age you should just let
go and like chill I kind of want to kill
Christian too though for being a bad
criminal well she should she should have
offered a hundred dollars in the first
time cuz she only offered 25 grand I
think for 25 grand I probably go to the
police to look if I was a hit man
getting you just say no to the job but
now you know too much oh you can go down
criminal you're supposed to have a
strong conscience he's new
or he could have been like the guy that
acts like the bad boy in the senior
citizen home or the tough guy like he
always had stories of like back in a day
but he's really a giant [ __ ] yeah like
he was like the guy that kind of new
stories of like the Salt Lake City mafia
or some [ __ ] like you like the guy that
hung out at the bar yeah because she
he's not even a criminal is just this
dude that has like neck tattoos and she
hired him to do some Sochi stereotype
[Applause]
she's like you looked like a kind of guy
that knows murderers yeah how do you
strike up a conversation and he's all
like 425 thousand I guess I could find
someone and he's like this is wrong I
feel like that's exactly how it went
down
like honestly like you know people right
you were tattoos yeah she's like this
old white lady you know you look kind of
comfortable murdering people one of
those tattoos probably means murder
right yeah I didn't you're not too over
her now she's facing life in prison
I mean she's 70 so yeah she [ __ ] up
her little life looks and she's still
trying to kill from prison yeah what did
this ex-husband would do is there any
store I don't think he did anything they
thought this crazy [ __ ] like she caused
everything Wow 70 years of being a [ __ ]
man how do you even survive I'm
surprised she doesn't have cancer with
all that stress you like they were lady
in my apartment just like that apartment
complex and green lady yeah the one that
like just she's on everybody about their
laundry all the time like she knows all
of our laundry baskets by heart wonder
about the one that we have in our play
you know the thing with old people is
they're either really [ __ ] grumpy or
really [ __ ] chill yeah and it's like
there's no yeah there's no in-between
whether you had regrets in life that's
why you need to just make the right
choices or let the wrong truth yeah yeah
what kind of old people do you guys
think you'll be you know I was watching
we're watching the news yesterday pick
up bells Emmer's we're watching the news
history and there's this guy named
Oliver hurricane Rodgers and he's a
hundred and he just completed like a 5
or 10k or something like that and he
still and he still run dry what did he
eat at nobody wears medals and he said
he was sitting in his like lazy boy
thing with the medals like the old
people lazy boy why he was just say like
stiff already belliston moving I bet he
was hot when he was younger he's
attractive yeah I was in the military
Oh My Damn a hundred shit's crazy tell
why the personality
[Music]